みなさんこんにちは
皆さんエコ
っていうと東でエコロジー思いと思います
であたくしが小さいときこのエコロジーというのが
ものの価値になるとはこれっぽっちも思っていませんでした
でも今もし環境にやさしい洗剤とそうでない洗剤があったときに
少し高くても環境に優しい洗剤をとっていうかまぁそういう経験をする人というのは
たくさんいると
これって言うのはエコロジーというのがものの価値になったということのショートです
今我々はこんな感じで新しいものの価値というものを新たに我々から提案できないかと
いうことを考えています
でその価値っていうのは何か
エコあれまた以下稼働
しかしこのエコエコロジーメイクではありません下に書いてあるように共感と助け合い
empathy &コーポレーションこれを略してエコと読みます
で我々はこの共感と助け合いをうまく生かしたものづくりの方法論とか発想の仕方
それを共感高額というふうに名付けています
まず最初にこの峡観光学というものはいったい何を意味してるのかというのをみなさん
に少し感じてもらうために一つの映像を見てもらおう
全庁あげましょうか
ありがとうござい
ああああああああ
じゃ
これで入って
あれ
電池きれいかよ
やはり携帯電話網とかスマートフォンまあ皆さんお持ちだと思いますけどなぜあるが
便利なのかというといつでもどこでも話ができるし中止ができるのです
ただそれができない時言って二つありますひとつは電波が届かないところに行って
しまうと思うんです
これに関しては
えっとたくさんの携帯電話の会社が
今では90%ねディアを守らせるということですのでまぁこれは少し横に置いておき
ましょう
でもう一つが電車がなくなってしまった時です
この中でも
電池切れてすごく焦ったという気持ちになった人はもうたくさんいると思いますほぼ税
じゃないでしょ
そういう時に皆さんならどうするでしょう
今ですと
このようにカフェに入って少し充電させてもらう
まあ今こういうカフェもたくさん増えましたしそれ以外のところでも充電できる場所と
いうのはたくさんせました
でこれで我々ばもう一度いつでもどこでも使えるということにができるようになるわけ
です
ただ今映像で見せたように
もしたくさん余裕のある電池に余裕なる人が電池の足りない人に分けることができた
もし携帯電話やスマートフォンにそういう機能がついてるとしたらこれでもやっぱり
我々はいつでもどこでも携帯電話を使うことができますしかもこれコンセントなんて
必要ないです
周りに助けてくれる人誰かがいればいい
なのでもしかしたらヤム多くの中で急に困っても誰かに助けてもらえば我々はまた携帯
電話を使うことができる
しかもこれは共感と助け合いによって機能が達成される
もう一つ例を挙げましょう
今日皆さんここに来るときに通ずにをれましたでしょうか
こういうイベントをするときによく
このような案内板を出します
まあこの坂田枚とホールというのは実はこの会場ではなくてこの少し裏にある長いだけ
の別の会場ですけども
ここというのは初めて行く人にとっては少しわかりずらいのでこういう案内板をよく
使います
ただこの案内板まあ私から言わせるとあまり共感工学的ではない
例えばこんな風に作り変えています
矢印帰してしまってお越しの方はこちらの箱をとっ
箱の上には中を見て下さいとか言っ
そしたら実際この案内板を置いてみたらどうなるかちょっと見てみましょう
でプレイ向こう側から3名の人が着
で中開けます
でこの箱の中っていうのは地図とかが入っているわけではなくて単に
とある有名キャラクターのぬいぐるみが入ってるだけですなので彼らは何だこれはと
ちょっと入っているはずです
で締めてそのまま去っていきます
で実はこの3名の人は坂田平田ホールを知ってる人たちでした
次舌の2名男性がまた中を開きます
きっと待った彼らも何だこれはと言って家がありません
で重要なのは彼らが去ったあとですよく見ていてくださいもうすぐ彼らがあります
そうすると別の男性が現れます
でパッと見てぱっと締めてパッドさっちゃう
残念ながら最後の男性は中のぬいぐるみを面白がってくれることすらしてくれません
です
ただこれ何が起きたかと言いますと一番最後の男性は実は坂田平田ホールの場所を知ら
なかったです
しかし前の2名がこの箱を見ているということはあるどうも彼らは自分と同じ目的を
持っているつまり
坂平たホールに行こうとしているということを彼は理解しました
ということで当然
ぬいぐるみ面白がって暇なんてなくて一生懸命あの前の2にあの人はついていた
で却下的にあの男性はさから平田方につくことができたと言う
で案内板の機能というのはなんだったかっていうと知らない人をある目的地に到達させ
るって言うのがその機能目的な
ということはこの我々の提案して新しい
案内板というものもその機能をきちんと果たしているしかも共感と助け合いを使って
です
ただこういう神っていうのは実はたくさん身の回りであります
例えば見知らぬ土地で渋滞にはまってしまった時によく思うのは
なかなかナビでも抜け道を教えてくれても美味い抜きぬき道を教えてくれることはあり
ません
ただ目の前にいる車を見てナンバーを見て
中に乗ってる人の様子を見て車全体の様子を見てどう見てもこれは地元の車ダート
我々に色紙
いうことがあります
その車がすっと横道に逸れて行ったもう間違いなくコレは地元の人だけが知っている
抜け道をいくに違いない
で私はそれを後ついてこれ今の案内ばと全く同じ仕組みになっています
でこれでうまく抜けられるともうこれはもはや6ナビを超えた性能を持っています
これも持ちの共感と助け合いです
また別のシーンでは例えば我々が大好きなアーティストのライブに行くと
そうすると目の前にそのアーティストの t シャツを着たお客さんがいる
もう間違いなくその帰りについていけば我々はライブ会場に着くことができ
そうですしさらに待っている間もうもう自分と同じ趣味を持った人だということは認識
してますからもしかしたらそこで
新たな交流が生まれると思う
これが共感高額の可能性だと思います
で少しづづにしてまとめるとこの考え方っていうのは人と人とが共感し助け合うことで
ある目的を達成しようこれが共感高額のことです
でもしかするとさらに別のバリュー思われるかもしれないこれが共感高額の可能性
を意味しています
でこのことを考えるとある一つのことに気づきます
ものづくりのあり方っていうのを考えたときに今我々はそのもの本当にアクセスできる
ものハードウェアとしなものがあってそれを機能するためシステムとしている
ソフトウェア
これでだいたい全てのモノとモノの機能というのは達成されるわけですけども本当は
違うんじゃないか
本当はもう一つ中心に人の気持ち
人の心の動きは我々はこのマインドウェアと呼んでるんですが
このマインドウェアの周りにソフトウェアがあって
そしてそれにアクセスするためのものが
これが次の時代の新しいものを作るの考え方ではないかというふうに私は思っています
で
一つここで強調したいのは
決して我々はその教官とか助け合いの心を押しつけるようなもの作るしたいと言って
いるわけではありません
実は今日監督が助け合いの心というのはここにいる皆さんの心の中にすでに存在して
いるものです
なのでそれをうまく生かして
より効果的により効率的に機能させるようなものの設計値しそれを共感こう書くと
ちょっとここで例題を上げています例えば
効率の良いクルマをつくろう
これもし機械工学を専攻している人たちであれば何をするかというと
きっと効率のよいエンジンを作ろうとするでしょ
もし情報工学を専門としている人だったら
いいナビゲーションシステムを作ろうとするでしょう
でもしこれをじゃあ今日観光学で作ろう
なったらまあ一つの一例ですが私だったら
もう2人で乗りたくて仕方がなくなるような車を作ります
これ別に車の機能何も上がりません
ただ毎朝一人で通勤にプルマを使っていた人が必ず2人で伸びような
もうすぐ分かりますの皆さん人ひとり当たりの効率が一気にこれで2倍に上昇します
これが長官工学科
で今われわれはこれをいかに世の中に広めるかということを
学生を中心とした仲間たちと一緒に模索してい
この学生というのは名古屋大学だけでもないし
理系だけでもありません例えばいろいろな大学の経済とか心理とかデザイン芸術
そういう情報ありとあらゆるところから学生の人たちが集まって今一緒に考えています
で具体的に
どのようにそういう共感高額の発想を持ったものを考えているかと言うと
実は私たちの身の回りにもこういう共感工学的なものというのはすでにたくさんあり
ます
でここに書いてあるのはここに示したのはその
皆さんが見つけてきた共感個買ってきたもののフィールドワークの一部です
まあ一部ちょっと漢字の間違いがあるんですがまあここでは問わないかと思った
で
こうやって見つけてきた今日観光学的なものをちょっと別のものに応用してみようと
そうすると新しいアイディアというものが浮かんで
ちょっとここで皆さんのエクササイズ洗いましょう皆さんの
身の回りで今の話を聞いて今ちょっと感じたことがあってあれこれって共感工学って
いうやつかなぁと思うの何か思いつきます
例えば私だったら
これ簡単ですねエレベーターの開けるのボタンです
これとっても共感工学的だと僕は思っています
なぜならコレオスシーンというのは一つは向こうから来る人あ待って待ってますよ早く
おいでって言っときましょうですもう一つは降りるときにお先にどうぞ
いう気持ちを表すときこのボタン押します
このボタンですごく気持ちを表すことなんです
でも結果として何が起きてるかというと扉が開いている時間が最適化されています
これをちょっと他のプロダクトに応用してみましょう
皆さんだったら何に応用しますか
例えば
押しボタン信号
あれって一人で押すときってすごく
勇気がいりますよねなぜならをしてそしたらたくさんの車が停まってそこ
自分一人がわたってずっと振り向くと自分はすっかりばかり終わってるのにまだ慎吾は
釜玉までたくさんの車はどんどん止まっていく
中火ない気持ちになります
もしあれに元に戻すボタンというのはついていてくれたら
きっと我々はそれでありがとうという気持ちを表せますし向こうもどういたしましたと
いう気持ちとなるでしょ
しかも
教官とタスキ愛というものを使って信号が変わっている時間というものはきちんと最適
化されます
このように我々はまあアイディアを考えるまぁこれはいいです
愛者ただやっぱり実践してみないと何も意味があります
というのでちょっと私今からちょっと実践しています
ちょここに
袋があるんですが
中を見るといろんなものが
まぁちょっと
こういうのは
私工学部ですので
でもう少しいてみます
と
テーブルもありていると
ロード
ポケットには
田地元なくなりそうな境内テーマが
都合よく入って
で例えば行使するともうこれなんとナップ携帯電話ちょっと不恰好が携帯なんですけど
で携帯電話
で実は今ここにもう1セット
これが入っています
次期色は違う
ちょっと大分なんか皆さん意味がわかってきたと思うんですがどなたか私の
待っているこの電源を助けてくれるかさ
いらっしゃいませんでしょ
いいですかちょっとアナ
ません
でちょっとこれをお借りしてきましたでこれを
少し管理して
これでまあ普通セット
できました
でこれでえっとまぁ今これで2セット出来たのでまぁ少し私の東宝から
彼のほうから私の方に電源をもらってみようと思います
ちょっとつきました今これ充電可以子です
っていうようにまあこれ皆さん分かるように一番最初私が見せた
あの映像のものそのものですフィッターの映像を見た時にこういうややこしいものを
作るの大変だろうなぁと思ったと思うんですけど実はこれあの通販で買えるものを少し
集めれば実は荒れてすぐ
出現することができます要はアイデアっていうのはアイデアで終わらすと何の意味も
なくてやってみるかやってみないかここがすごく大きな境になります
で
ただ
これが製品になるたまあ皆さん思えません
で
ここからはやはりテクノロジーというものが必要になっています
で私は今えっと
学生のアイディアと
企業の持つ技術をマッチングするという月どうも同時にあっています
こちらの映像はついこの前あったんですが学生と企業のマッチングの様子です
この時には学生チームが4つのアイディアを持っていました
それに対して約30社の企業がこれに対していろいろマッチングして
今現在もこのうちのいくつかはプロジェクトとして
チークをしています
今日学生の方も多くいらっしゃると思うんですか皆さん想像してみてください皆さんの
10水で熱い情熱を持ったアイディアが企業の皆さんが少しずつ具現化して製品近いも
仕上げて入ってくる
これすごくワクワクしますよね
私はこの様子を見てこの2つのコラボレーションこそがもしかしたらこの純粋な
アイディアに基づくものづくりこそが次のイノベーションのためになるのではないかと
いうふうに信じています
ところで私自身は普段は材料工学のバリバリの研究者です
最近よくがありますうちある先生最近なにしてるんですかと
でも僕は今思っています
これまでテクノロジーというのはダイレクトに
例えば環境を良くしてきたりエネルギーを減らしてきたりそういうことをやってきたん
ですが実が本当は誰もが世の中を良くしたいという気持ちがある
実を言うとテクノロジーっていうのはそういうみんなが世の中を良くしたいという
気持ちをもっと
応援するようなもっとみんなが素直にこの世の中の木に気持ちを走られるようなそう
いうところに実はテクノロジーを使った方が
持っての中効率よくよくなるのではないかというふうに私は知って最近聡明ながら自分
の研究もし
で最後に
2,020円これ東京オリンピックです
でこの時にはたくさんの外国人がやってきます
でその人たちは日本にあるいろんなものを手にとって
こう思うでしょなんか優しい気持ちになるねとなんか日本のものって
人とつながれぬような気がするね仲間が増えるなと
こういうようなまあいわゆるエボタウンというものができないかというふうに私は弓
ただこれは私自身だけの力では無理で
ここにいる皆さんとか多くの方の知恵
技術知識いろいろなものの集約が必要であるというふうに思っています
どうでしょう今日私の話を聞いて少し何かアイディアがんだ人とかちょっと何か作って
みたいなと思った人も少しはいるんじゃないかと思う
ぜひもしそういうふうに思いましたら私たちと一緒に
新しいものの価値を作るというのをやっていきましょう
今日はどうもありがとうございました